Speaker 1: Let's go next to let's go
to Rich from Illinois. Rich, welcome.
Speaker 4: Hi, David.
Speaker 1: Hello.
Speaker 4: So I was the top model of the Donald on
Reddit for years until just before it was banned.
And with Elan buying Twitter, do you think
that there will be a general shift in policy
for the tech places towards allowing themes
like medical misinformation, such as ivermectin
and what Vice's motherboard did yesterday with
tweeting out my proposal for abortion pills.
Speaker 1: What I didn't see the what's
the vice thing? Tell me about that.
Speaker 4: Yeah. So they tweeted out from
their motherboard account that Meisel proposal,
which is a horse medicine to treat ulcers
for horses, can be used for abortion pills.
Speaker 1: Oh, I see that now. Yeah. Okay, so
let's go step by step first. I actually discussed
this with Coleman Hughes in an already recorded,
but not yet released podcast episode with him.
I actually don't think that Elon Musk
taking over Twitter if it happens, remember,
it's still not been approved. And I think it may
not be, but we'll wait and see. I don't think it's
going to do anything mind blowing on Twitter, per
se. I think maybe some people will be unbanned,
maybe not. I don't know that he is widely going
to be involved in content moderation. So I'm kind
of I'm not making any big judgments about what's
going to change on Twitter. Let's first wait and
see if the buyout actually happens. And then we'll
kind of think about that part in terms of I mean,
listen, I don't know much about this misoprostol
thing, but I also don't know whether this is
an approved off label use or not. I don't know
anything about it. But let me just say right now,
all of this stuff said it should be subject to
the same scrutiny, whether it's being promoted
by left or right, I think it all should be
subjected to the exact same terms of service.
Speaker 4: Okay. That's good.
Speaker 1: Now, let me ask you. So
you were a you were a top moderator on The Donald,
which was widely considered one of the most toxic
enclaves of the Internet until it
was banned. Are you a Trump guy?
Speaker 4: I am.
Speaker 1: Wow. And
so and now what do you think about like do
you believe ivermectin works to treat COVID?
Speaker 4: And I don't know,
because I'm not a doctor.
Speaker 1: Okay. How would you do? Do
you think Advil works for headaches?
Speaker 4: I do.
Speaker 1: And why do you
regret not being a doctor?
Speaker 4: See how
it does. For some people. It does. It doesn't
for others. Ibuprofen works for others. Better
than Advil does. Or or, you know, other things.
Speaker 1: Ibuprofen and Apple are the same thing.
Speaker 4: Yeah. Yeah, aspirin.
Speaker 1: That's what I'm okay.
But so why do you not being a doctor, why do
you feel so strongly about your knowledge of
ibuprofen and not ivermectin?
Speaker 4: I no, no.
Yeah. That wasn't the the kind of gist of what
I was trying to get at the fact that people
were getting banned for mentioning off label
use of ivermectin, which is approved drug for
humans, but it's not or not even covered.
Speaker 1: You agree that without right.
Speaker 4: I well, I don't know. But like I
said, I'm not a doctor, so I don't pretend to.
Speaker 1: Wait a second. Hold on a second.
See, the problem is. Whenever I ask you a direct
question, you say, I don't know because I'm not
a doctor. But you just asserted you do know that
ivermectin is, quote, approved for humans, but
isn't how do you know that without being a doctor?
Speaker 4: Well, I know that
ivermectin is approved for
humans because that is actually documented.
Speaker 1: So I'm saying I don't know. I'm not
a doctor. You would just say I don't know.
Speaker 4: Okay.
Speaker 1: Yeah. So if I were to assert to you
that the way we figure out if a medication works
for a condition is to do a randomized controlled
trial. Would you agree that that's a good way to
figure out whether a medication works?
Speaker 4: I do believe in science,
so I would agree 100% with that.
Speaker 1: Beautiful. And if I told you
that there were two randomized controlled trials
which looked at ivermectin for COVID and neither
showed that it did anything, would that be
compelling if you were to see those studies?
I know you haven't seen them, but given that
you've accepted the randomized controlled trial,
if randomized controlled trials said it
doesn't work for COVID, would that satisfy you?
Speaker 4: Oh, of course it would.
Speaker 1: Okay, good. All right. Well, those
studies exist. Check out my clips on them. Okay?
Speaker 5: Okay.
Speaker 1: All right. You still like Trump?
Speaker 4: Well, I was going to say this. My
so personal thing is being out there and
they are being banned for even though
it's not approved for use on humans.
Speaker 1: They are not being
banned. You're saying?
Speaker 4: No. Yeah.
Speaker 1: Yeah. Listen, this is the first I heard
about it, so I'm not trying to cop out. Like it or
not, these claims should all be managed in the
same way. But in terms of terms of service, you
know, we have to have the same rules, no matter
whether it's hydroxy or misoprostol or whatever.
I just don't know anything about my supposed.
All right now. So I can't say. Okay, there.
Speaker 3: Yep.
Speaker 1: All right. Thanks so much for the call.
Speaker 4: Appreciate it.
Thanks for taking. No problem.
Speaker 1: All right. So you guys look at that.
What a conversation. We were able to do it.